hello everyone and welcome to a really
really crazy game that was played today
in the Asian Championship it's always a
ferocious versus morally Karthikeyan not
sure if I pronounced that I'm sure you
will school me in the comments if I if I
didn't but it's one of those games that
when you see it and when it happens it
doesn't happen very often you just wanna
show it to your friends and family
because it's just that good
now when I first saw it I thought wow
this is just like a news media versus
Chernykh of 1962 the famous Queen
sacrifice but then again it happened
today were in 2019 so that's pretty
weird between two very strong
grandmasters and I don't know yeah I
don't know I didn't know what to make of
it but better for me just to show it to
you and then you can decide for
ourselves so without further ado I'll
Reza has the white pieces and he opens
with d4 so nothing extraordinary in the
opening just a nice Kings Indian defense
we have c4 g6 Knight to c3 Bishop to g7
and now for we have d6 and now h3 we
have castles by black Bishop to e3 now
c5 attacking the center and nice to f3
we have Queen to a5 putting pressure on
this on the center as the night is now
pinned and here night the detorri
maneuvering the night over to b3 at the
kick away the Queen we see capture some
d4 here and now comes Knight to b3 and
this is where the magic happens it's
only move 9 and this position has been
reached before between Mario Corso and
Tamara
sisty GC ah cava and in that game Queen
to h5 was played where white was able to
win the game after Bishop Bishop to e2
and the game continued normally but this
game did not continue in this fashion
after Knight to b3 the strongest move
recommended by the engineers just queen
e5 a nice central any move by the Queen
white recaptures the pawn and the game
continues but that's for engines to play
to play this game here
Murali mortally played a brilliant move
and it's exactly the one that reminded
me of a near
the universe's genic of Queen captures
on c3 and it's just amazing if you're if
you don't remember and you know versus
Cherenkov Cherenkov played a similar
sacrifice as his queen was here he
played Queen captures on f6 where where
the bishop was attacking the Queen but
very similar and it's very interesting
Karthikeyan sacrifices the Queen unmoved
nine so not like churning called unmoved
twelve against uh and that's like
carnage Medina against Jeremy : or 12
and not like Kasparov against Chronicle
move 12 also really crazy Queen
sacrifice also with the black pieces but
let's just see what happens Queen
captures on c3 will be captures on c3
and now pawn captures on d3 and now you
might think okay but where's the
exchange well that's the beauty probably
with perfect play why should what you'll
get on top but it's the same in in news
Medina vs. chernakoff so here already an
improvement to White's continuation here
white played f3 and he allowed like to
keep his pawn on e3 which is very
dangerous here if you just play Bishop
to d3 continue developing you allow this
then okay you can bring the rook into
the game you can artificially castle
maybe a slight improvement here few
doors are played f3 and now comes Knight
to h5 already white created some dark
square weaknesses around the black King
and also Bishop captures on c3 would be
a pretty big threat as you would also
lose the rook and while you do have
material compensation at the moment if
you lose from the rook along with your
two pieces then black will definitely
have the upper hand
so here Queen the c1 defending the c3
pawn and just push up to h6 now
defending the pawn here we have g4 by
white pushing the right back Knight to
f4 and here again you have some threats
for example if you eliminate the pond
and Knight checks here the King and you
will lose the Queen as you open up this
very nice discovery so I've tried the
form we have king to d1 by future
getting the King out of the way not
allowing any checks with the night and
also preparing to hide it over over on
the Queen side and here Knights the e6
again creating some very nice threats
here upon the e2 check would again win
the Queen
so the Rajah has to
way we have King to see to and I was
just Knight to c6 starting to bring the
other pieces into the game and white
still has I mean white is still better
if you found the material but it's very
hard to develop the pieces and it's very
hard to find a viable game plan very
similar to tough to the news Medina vs.
chernakoff so here white played h4 he
wants to close this diagonal for the
bishop by playing g5 with Bishop to f4
not allowing that and now Quinta d1 just
getting the Queen out of the way no
longer you have to be afraid of any pawn
pushing and here just Knights the e5 so
bring your pieces closer to the king you
put pressure on the c4 pawn you wanna
develop the bishop bring the rook over
to c8 we have Knights the c1 now the
idea is to bring the knight over to d3
or ET to attack the bishop on f4 and
rush up to d7 and now again you cannot
really move the knight right away
because Bishop to a4 would again win the
Queen here so even a seemingly peaceful
move like Bishop to d7 comes with a
deadly threat we have a four by white
and out the rook is guarding the pawn on
e4 so no Bishop a4 will be possible and
rook a to ca again continuing to put
pressure on the C file as the the
sequence or W will probably not be able
to defend both of them and with your
King being and the Queen side the rooks
will most likely be doubled on the on
the on the C file and it's gonna be very
intense and here a few Roger plays
Knight studies nights to e2 and the
Knights to e 2 is not the most precise
way to deal with this position the best
idea is nice - d3 because here well
let's just show why night to d3 is
better here if Knight to d3
then if you capture on c4 of course you
will get Knight captures and f4 and
after Knight captures on f4 Queen to e 1
where you will threaten to win the night
and c4 and also you will just eliminate
these report which is very important but
the biggest problem is after Knight 2 D
3 black cannot save everything by
playing Bishop h6 like black did
actually in the game because here you
just capture on e5 and you lose the
bishop on these 7 that's the problem but
here if you don't have played nice that
e to and it seems like the same idea ok
if Knight captures 0 I'll just captured
a bishop and we
into the line that we've already shown
but here black can go Knight Bishop to
e6 and now your knight is not on d3 so
you cannot capture here the bishop on d7
and 107 is safe
we have g5 closing up this diagonal
brush up to g7 and now Bishop to h3 and
by firaga now comes Knight captures on
f3 we have Queen to d3 finally going
after that III pawn and now Knight back
to e5 we have Queen captures on d3 you
finally get rid of this you know nasty
pawn and just Knight captures on c4 so
black slowly but surely gobbles up for
all of the pawn around the black King we
have Queen to f2 and now comes Luke the
c5 as planned the black now plans to
double rooks on the C file where he will
put pressure on the c3 pawn the the
bishop also puts pressure here on the
pawn and it will be very hard for white
to defend with rook H the b1 now
just transferring the game over to the
Queen side and we have Bishop to c6 now
defending the b7 pawn but for a moment
you will not be able to double rooks and
the C file we have Bishop back to g2 now
defending this pawn here as on the
previous move black attacked it and now
f5 black just wants to open lines as the
king is on c2 and there aren't all that
many pieces defending it G captures on
f6 and basan with Bishop captures on f6
now with ideas of winning this pawn you
wanna for example if the Queen moves you
will be able to play something like rook
aged 5 win this pawn and then slowly but
surely win even more material
so here surendra finds a different idea
he plays rook to f1 and he actually
allows some nasty discoveries here
because the Queen is still on the same
file as a black stroke on f8 so here
what do you do well Bishop captures on
c3 Karthikeyan grabs the c3 pawn and
here comes Queen captures on c5 Rocio
decides to give up the Queen to win back
some material the problem is you don't
really have a good response if you move
the Queen to g3
then Bishop e5 attacks the Queen yes you
can exchange rooks here Knight captures
rook after side captures but then again
your queen is under attack
after you move the Queen you will get
night the III check then you go after
the bishop every King do to you will
capture here ninth chapter Sanji to
attack the Queen after the Queen moves
you will play Bishop captures an a.1
Queen captures Bishop captures here and
here you will have two knights a bishop
and the rook against the Queen and the
night which the King being well without
any protection on b2 and the black is a
black has six points Judas would be
completely winning for black so after
Bishop captures on c3 Pharaohs I decided
to give but to give back the Queen but
also to win some material Queen captures
on c5 with Knight captures on c5 and now
a trader Brooks we look after screen
captures and King captures and c3 now
and the night goes back to e5 so here
black did black was able to win back
some material and if you count the
pieces black is even of the white is
even up the exchange but similarly to
the game Nunez Medina versus China cough
where were Jenica was Abdi exchange and
mr. Medina just had better pieces
placement and he had more pawns so yeah
I mean it's just a much better endgame
here we have a five getting this point
away from a forward where it's a target
but now you can protect both the a a
four point and the e4 pawn so knife
captures with check with Bishop captures
Bishop captures and now Knight study for
we have Bishop to d5 and now comes
Knights the b5 just defending that a
seven point we have a six nights the c7
now going after the bishop and the
bishop the c6 rook to f1 check King to
g7 and knights to e6 check and here
black doesn't mind just came to h6
where you're asking why are you really
gonna play this I'm sure you're still up
the exchange but it's a six points to
two and an exchange up is is no
compensation for being down four points
so we have a look to f8 and I trying to
get some action from from behind the
scenes but you know the bishop is
controlling the b7 pawn your it's very
hard to defend to attack this pawn the
visual controls discord the knight
controls this square so we don't really
have have a target for your rook I mean
it's a very very very difficult position
for white King to h5 going after the h5
before pawn but knocking a roof to h8
threatening to capture on h7 with h6 now
comes rook to h7 just waiting for black
to make a move and also attacking the e7
pawn king captures on h4 now now you
don't want to have to connect at past
bonds to start marching forward rook
captures and he's on h6 we have king to
g4 and now Knights the d4 attacking the
bishop here but black doesn't mind we
have Kings to g5 attacking the rook rook
to h2 and out Bishop to d5 still keeping
the bishop on the board as it's a very
nice piece defending the backwards b7
pawn we have rook to e 2 and now comes
King to f4 black just brings the King
into the game rook to have to check
Knight to f3 and not look to e2 with E 5
black now starts pushing his central
pawns as well with nice to see two and
out boishakh to e4 again threatening to
exchange more material Knights the e3
and here d5 threatening d4 we have King
Tubby 4 and here Knights the d4
attacking the rook we have rook to e1
and here after king of three it was in
this position I'll move 52 that
al-gaddafi Rosa resigned the game and
well he resigned there's no more
pointing needing this game I've played
some like King c5 just king of two wins
you attack both the knight and the rook
and if you don't if you play something
like well you don't really have a good
square for the knight you could try
something like Knights the d1 but then
just write the C to check the King and
wins the rook so really an amazing game
by Karthikeyan who really reminded me of
the game is really no versus Cherenkov
but you know let's just see it one more
time I would I would say in slow motion
but you know just look at this position
of Queen captures on c3 that's just
beautiful and for those of you who don't
remember this is the position in the
game Jericho versus engineers Medina of
we're sharing of attackers with eNOS
Queen and the original just grabbed the
best of Queen captures on f6 so quite
similar to this one where were
Queen captures on c3 was played Maria
just an amazing game and I'm very happy
that it happened you know it's really
improved my day hope it did the same for
you and yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to thank
Mario and Sonata for a contribution to
my channel thank a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here thank y'all
for watching and I will see you soon
hopefully much more interesting content
continuing the coverage of the ultimate
championship and you know checking up on
your suggestions and such for those of
you who by some chance haven't seen this
renewal versus Chernykh oh it will be
the first link in the description below
so do check it out thank you all I will
see you soon have an excellent rest of
your day